time for the press preview first look at
what is on tomorrow's front pages
and tonight we'll see what's making the
headlines with the communications
advisor and former aide to boris johnson
guitar harry and the political
correspondent at politics joe
nadine bachelor hunts a very good
evening to both of you we'll chat in a
moment first of all let's check out some
of those front pages for you
starting with the metro carry the can
is their headline as the prime minister
says he loves
john lewis well the sun reports that
carrie simons has been invited to appear
on strictly come
dancing and could use her earnings to
fund
the downing street refurbishment
on the front of the express boris
johnson hits back at his critics saying
he is focusing on the post-pandemic
recovery
the telegraph says social distancing at
major events will
end on the 21st of june after initial
results from a pilot scheme
found no spike in cases
let's slide in the mail for you the
number of people falling ill with covet
is said to have fallen to the lowest
level
since the pandemic began the ft
says that the u.s economy is recovering
strongly thanks to a fiscal
stimulus package and the country's
successful vaccine rollout
at the orcs post quotes transport
secretary grant shaps as saying that
construction of the hs2 rail project
should probably have started in the
north
and the star reports on the end of the
drama series
line of duty happening this weekend
and i'm joined tonight by guitar harry
and the dean bachelor hunt a very good
evening to both of you
good to see you plenty to go on uh in
the papers
um why don't we start then with the
front of the metro
uh guitar why don't you you kick things
off be good to get your thoughts on
on where we are now and interestingly a
couple of papers the metro
and the sun both have got pictures of of
carrie
simons um sort of pointing the finger at
her
somewhat i mean is this is this slightly
sexist do you think is
she the right person to be being blamed
it feels sexist doesn't it it feels like
a cheap shot it feels like they can't
quite get at the prime minister so they
go
for the partner um i think in all
honesty the
the the wallpaper the taste the interior
design is almost certainly
uh hers because you know for my
knowledge of the prime minister he
really doesn't care very much what's
hanging on the wall not
indeed what is on the floor beneath his
feet so i think it's fair enough to
to assume that she's responsible for the
decorations but unfair i think to drag
her into a political row and i have to
say the whole thing
seems largely ridiculous and what we
have tonight when there are so many
critical
things going on in the uk and in the
world is both
kierstarmer as the leader of the
official opposition and the prime
minister boris johnson having to
uh plead to us that they are both fans
of john lewis because somebody must have
told them that the focus group suggests
that
being harsh on john lewis is bad for all
those sort of swing voters somewhere in
the middle there who rely on stores like
that
yeah keto i'm just just going to stay
with you because you say it's all
vaguely ridiculous and it has got some
what farcical i have to say on the front
pages but there are three investigations
into this flat refurbishment um
even the parliamentary commissioner for
standards
today saying that there could well be a
fourth so
to people watching this program and
people reading the papers um
they're going to be furious aren't they
yeah furious and what furious because
all that sort of legal expertise is
being devoted into
checking out who actually if anyone did
provided a sort of interim uh payment
to facilitate something that the prime
minister has made very clear he ended up
paying for himself so we're just talking
about the
the nature of the financing if there was
anything
like a loan to get some work done we're
not talking about public money
we're talking about private money that
may not have been declared properly if
that
the idea that three official
investigations should be launched into
this when we're mid pandemic
when there are all kinds of
complications for brexit when the world
has so many things to ponder
really is ridiculous and i must say you
know it's not to say that these things
don't matter at all
but they've been blown out of all
perspective okay let's find out what
nadine
uh has to say about it a new poll
tonight putting the tories 11 points
ahead gito saying that it's not
taxpayers
money and therefore it's not going to
cut through what do you think
uh i i think some of it is taxpayers
money i think the prime minister gets
30 000 pounds from the public purse
to uh renovate the flat so i don't think
it's entirely fair to say it's not all
public money unless i'm mistaken
i think more broadly um it's interesting
that the polls really aren't going to
make a massive difference when it comes
to what happens with the electoral
commission
and i think that to some level hmrc this
is quite interesting
and i wrote a piece earlier talking
about how it could be the al capone
uh moment for boris because at the end
of the day this doesn't matter
what it says in the polls what you know
how the conservatives are polling
it's what the electoral commission finds
and he could be interviewed under
caution if he's broken the rules
and we all are governed by rules we all
have to abide by the rules and we should
expect our prime minister to as well i
don't think
he should be an exception but i also do
agree there are also important things
going on
i think the reason this story is
important though is because what happens
with the electoral commission could
affect his premiership
and whether whether or not he's prime
minister this time next year and nadine
on the front page of the sun tango and
cash for curtains what would you make of
this
angle that carrie simons could hit the
strictly
dance floor the son is saying to fund
her 200 000 pound
flat refurbishment
um i find it quite distasteful this
stuff about curry i think on the front
page of the mail yesterday they had a
picture of her in a um a swimsuit as
well
at the end of the day and it was boris
johnson who um
you know organized this payment not
carry whatever the kind of ins and outs
of their relationship are when it comes
to interior design
the the book and the book stops with him
and i just think
that should be remembered in all of this
and we shouldn't be censoring his um
partner fiance we should be centering
boris johnson because
he is the prime minister and he should
really be able to deal with renovating a
flat without kind of getting into a
scandal you'd hope
our prime minister could do that um at
least let's take a look at the front of
the
daily express guitar laser-focused boris
takes aim at critics he's saying there's
nothing to
see here nothing to worry about but of
course when a politician says that
it simply makes journalists believe
there really is something
to see but number 10 really are pulling
up the drawbridge aren't they
well there are good things to be getting
on with and what is quite interesting
tonight we haven't seen all the papers
for tomorrow we've maybe
uh an hour from now we will see
something that is a new revelation
we don't have a new revelation now we
don't have anything new that's emerging
we just have
more and more inquiries and the
recycling and the you know rehashing
of of a story that's been around for
months actually that there were
renovations to the flat and nobody quite
knew who paid for them
um so it is one where there are more
important things and if you contrast
perhaps
uh you know the stories about the
wallpaper with the kind of stories about
what joe biden is doing in america with
with the challenges the hideous stuff
going on in
in places like india and all the rest of
it it does make
uh you know the whole thing look
ridiculous although
you know if you look at the list of
investigations there's the jennifer
curie affair there's mustique holiday
there's three investigations into the
flat
refurbishment there's the cameron
lobbying there's the dyson text i mean
it does all give a sense doesn't it of
um of chaos in many ways inside number
10 and it does bring into question the
prime minister's integrity doesn't it
it's good how you can just turn all
these separate things none of which are
particularly
menacing into a great big swirling cloud
and i have been
on the other side you know the first
term of boris johnson as mayor
people said it was chaos in the inside
because they were deputy mayors
resigning and stuff and on the inside
the focus was very much on cutting crime
and on
investing in transport and getting on
with the job now i'm not going to
pretend that it must be hunky-dory
inside number 10 at the moment it is
challenging these things are hugely
distracting
and it's a shame that there are such
distractions of the things that are
so ultimately trivial um if we take a
step back
do we really want our prime ministers to
be unable to serve
um dinners at you know czech as their
country retreat or
or to you know redecorate a flat and
it's not like you can call your mate in
uh to come and do the painting for you
it's a listed building with security
clearance
i imagine it's a nightmare to do up
flatter number 10 and really they should
be allowed to sort of get on with it and
we should judge them on whether we think
brexit is the right thing
and whether the handling of the pandemic
is the right thing and whether we think
that
you know the sort of conduct in
parliament is the right thing and that
in the end
is something that boris johnson has
proved time and time again that because
he doesn't pretend to be white and white
uh on a sort of personal human level
people have got used to that
they should judge him whatever he does
as prime minister well that leads us
very nicely on to the daily mail
nadim because the headline there is what
a boost for britain
vaccine for almost all over 40s
infections plummet almost 50 million
jabs
given things are going incredibly well
with a vaccine rollout we're in a good
place
in this country and that is what people
are going to be focusing on isn't it
i think it's some really much needed
good news after you know
well over a year now really of lockdown
um and yeah it is some good news i think
it's a nice relief to kind of hear
something that's not
the uh the flat thing although it is
important the flat thing is important
i've had both of my vaccines um my mom's
have both of her vaccines
and we've been shielding for quite a
long time so i'm looking forward to
being able to
get out into the world again and i know
there'll be a lot of other people who
were shielding who probably felt that
they were a bit ignored
that are going to be looking forward to
getting back to normal and i'm just
looking forward to be able to go to the
pub and hug my mates and not have to
worry about
you know infecting them or at least not
worry as much
um but yeah i mean the figures are uh
fantastic gito
aren't there there's there's uh there's
no denying that only 757
symptomatic cases a day in england the
chance now of getting infected
is as low as one in one hundred and
fifty thousand for those like nadine
who've had
both jabs yes and my
my arm here is sought from having my
second jab yesterday and hopefully next
week
i'm gonna start jabbing other people
because i'm i'm a volunteer vaccinator
and
you know i can't wait to get uh stuck in
but um we we have turned the corner here
and it's a big
big thing and sometimes it's that
it's that sort of playing not fast and
loose but actually
not actually being so preoccupied with
process
and procedure and holding back and
ticking every box
that allows you that allows somebody
like boris johnson to get something like
the vaccine sorted that drive that
energy that sort of refusal to take no
uh from you know process obsessed people
that gets things done
and what we're starting to see now
there's gonna be a lot more of it
evidence of other things that we like
doing going back to the pub
there's talk about being able to go to
concerts football matches rugby matches
with a bit of luck there's a
lions you know test match going on
before they fly out to
south africa there's going to be a rugby
match in edinburgh be fantastic if
if there was a small crowd at least
there so there's all this
positive stuff to look forward to and i
really don't care who paid for the
wallpaper and number 10
um knowing in the end there's boris
johnson of course himself
i'm a bit concerned about you jabbing
people have you ever done that before
i've been trained and i must say it's a
tribute to
saint john's ambulance uh the nhs
healthcare workers that they have
managed to train
thousands of people who you need some
sort of basic knowledge but
uh yes they take you to another level
where you can hopefully um
do this thing safely excellent well good
luck um and nadine uh given
the success of the vaccine and the
rollout and all the data is looking
pretty positive
do you think we're right to stick to
this timetable it's still going to be
some time isn't it before
we're given all our freedoms back
i think it's hard to say i think the
obviously the epidemiologists and the
scientists know best
some of the concerns i've had are there
are people in care homes that um
have had both vaccines or um i've still
been told they can't do certain things
they can't go and see relatives if
they've also had two vaccines
there are things that i think need to be
looked at for example shielders who
haven't been out in months
perhaps they should be able to do
certain things before others i'm not
sure
i think it's it's a good timetable we're
going in the right direction but there
are some people who have had a much
tougher pandemic
than others particularly shielders
particularly people in care homes
and i think that needs to be looked at
you know if if uh
persons have both vaccines and and then
they're in a carefree and their
loved ones have two you'd hope that
they'd be able to see each other but i
think there's restrictions still on that
at the moment
yeah okay we'll leave it there for the
moment guiteau and nadine thank you very
much
because coming up in part two we're
going to take a look at the front of the
ft
and the us economy and president biden's
big
plans spending trillions that's after
the break
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me former aider boris
johnson guitar harry and the political
correspondent app politics joe nadine
bachelor hunt uh front page of the
financial times uh guitar why don't you
kick off part two
um i mean incredible numbers coming out
of the us when it comes to the economy
they really are and this gives me hope
you know we've seen a year of
every effort to the state being put into
stopping us doing stuff to stay at home
to close down
to not go out and this is a sign that
you know there could be
exciting times ahead because the us is
certainly motoring 6.4
gdp growth just imagine that what that
is happening
of course there's a huge injection of
money going in there there's a green
deal there's jobs there's infrastructure
investments
but there's a real sense from a man
actually who's you know not a spring
chicken
uh in the white house that energy that
ambition that sense of drive he's
talking about competing with china to
win the 21st century
this is really dynamic uplifting stuff
and i would love it if we go back to
that kind of stuff over here
uh it's something to look forward to if
if we can get there
yeah nadine he's shaking off the sleepy
joe tag isn't he
um do you share gito's optimism and
enthusiasm
i think joe biden's really um gone
beyond the expectations of many people i
think particularly those
um to the left of him i don't you know
biden always said that he wants to bring
people together
was going to bring together the right of
his party the left of his party
you know i think yesterday he was
tweeting about how trickle-down
economics just doesn't work
this is all very interesting coming from
biden a lot of people saw him as an
old-fashioned centrist
and he's kind of he's really hitting out
the park i've been very impressed
um and i would like to see that sort of
politics over here i would like to say
one thing though that things like
transgender rights
and i think they're more progressive
over there when it comes to and the
rhetoric that comes up and from
biden compared to some of the leaders
over here so i'd like to see some of
that brought over but yeah i
i think uh biden is doing very well and
i think he's exceeded expectations to on
those uh to those of the left of him
okay and nadine just staying with you
front of the daily telegraph uh tech
giants face
racism crackdown uh tell us about this
yeah so um anybody that's um kind of of
color or a minority on social media
knows how bad racism can be i think the
government's controversial race report
and
from a few weeks ago although there was
a lot on it that a lot of people
disagreed on
one of the things it did say is that
online abuse is something that's a
serious problem
and i'm finding it quite um heartening
to see more serious action being
out and done to deal with that you know
there are people of color that are
bullied off social media and we should
be able to use social media without
having torrents of abuse footballers
should be able to go and
play football without worrying that
they're going to have death threats and
you know being compared to monkeys
online that sort of stuff so it's really
good to see this although
i think there's a bit of a strange part
where it says ofcom will also get powers
to protect free speech from stopping
woke social media fans
woke has become a kind of meaningless
term i'm not entirely sure what they
mean by that
but i think it could only be um positive
in my view having experienced racism
online
yeah and guitar this comes doesn't it on
the eve of football's
weekend boycott of social media
yes and it's one of those things for a
long time if you're a broadcaster like
yourself
of course you know you have to abide by
certain rules uh you are responsible for
what goes out on your platforms the same
with newspapers
and it's long been a source of great
frustration for
established responsible media whatever
the political
viewpoints they have that they rightly
have to abide by certain standards but
there are other platforms out there
where it's a free-for-all it's anarchy
and um it's about time in a way though
i'm
i'm nervous about you know who curates
free speech there are big issues there
but it is it is good to see some sort of
move towards
making sure that these massive firms
that make huge profits have just a tiny
bit of the kind of
regulation and restraint uh that the
rest of us have to live by
okay we must leave it there gito nadine
great to speak to you thank you both